[Music]
hey guys my podcast is out now and this
entire episode is dedicated to creative
ways to get the word out
um i've worked really hard on this i'm
so out of breath
i've worked really hard on this and i'm
super proud of it but i don't know much
about the podcast world
the only thing i do know is that it's
really important for people to listen
obviously
so we're going to do just that in this
video we're going to get people to
listen in creative ways and i've saved
the best for last so make sure to stick
around to the end
so let's start with number one this is
the least creative but i believe the
most powerful is directed towards you
all
please consider listening to my podcast
it'll be linked in the description the
first episode is up now
all right i think that's pretty much it
let's get started
all the best things that i've seen
in all the most wonderful views
are the best sides
[Music]
all the best nights i never slept
all the days i'm holding on to
all the best
[Music]
all the best trees i drove down
all the towns i've wandered through
are the best
[Music]
than
ones
[Music]
the bed
[Music]
all right so there's obviously one last
thing i did but i wanted to say
something before i show you
please listen to the first episode of my
podcast it's out now and it's linked in
the description
subscribe and follow on whatever
platform you prefer to listen on
and it'll really help if you leave a
five star review on apple podcast
um okay now walk with me
if you've been subscribed to my channel
for a while you'll know that i have a
thing for billboards
unfortunately though they're super
pricey so i thought this time
i would be my own
[Music]
i know these winding roads
that lead
[Music]
oh man i'm getting kind of tired
hey tada you think you can hold this for
a second
thanks homie just like that
all right now that we have a minute to
relax here's a preview of my podcast
remember it's linked in the description
and the video version will be up this
friday
on my channel hey stranger
hello to everyone listening my name is
darya this is the hey stranger podcast
and before we start let me set the scene
for you i'm currently sitting in a chair
at my local park which also happens to
be one of the biggest tourist
attractions in my city
across from me is an empty chair and on
today's and every episode
that empty chair will be filled one by
one by people of different backgrounds
mindsets and walks of life the only
criteria
is that they are a stranger
okay that's it thank you guys so much
for watching thank you for everything
i love you all and i'll see you next
[Music]
hey time how much longer do i have to
stand here for
i'm good my the hardest part is how does
like the stopping
[Music]
here i come
[Music]
hey guys my my mouth's not working
y'all messing with me
uh so let's start hey guys my podcast is
out now okay i got it
i need to run faster i'm so out of
breath by the time i get here
get it right now the way you want all
that money all right let's go
[Music]
hey guys my podcast is out now and this
entire episode is dedicated to creative
ways to get the word out
um what else i got to keep this going
because my cousin bet me i need to
if i do it in one take she'll then move
me five bucks so let's just keep it
going i'm not sure
if someone could give me a clue on
what's next
[Laughter]
[Music]
hurry go go go go go
i don't know how to hop onto
okay
[Applause]
photoshop
oh my gosh people walking by i'm just
gonna act like a billboard
billboards don't talk yeah
oh one's blowing me whoopsies
i love you guys you're the best thanks
for everything
here's a preview of my podcast
alright that's it thank you so much you
okay there
i'm still recording you